let's get into that first story from the  New York Post Elon Musk fires Twitter  lawyer James Baker over Hunter Biden's  story suppression the funny thing is you  know if you just read the headline  you're like uh-huh why is that news okay  Elon Musk fired Twitter general counsel  okay so it's just straight general  counsel wow in light of concerns about  Baker's possible role in suppression of  information important to the Public  Public dialogue he was exited from  Twitter today musk wrote on Twitter  Tuesday musk added that he questioned  Baker before his firing about the events  surrounding the laptop suppression uh  Scandal and that his explanation was  unconvincing Baker was previously  general counsel for the FBI under former  director James Comey and was a key  figure in the bureau's investigation  into false claims of collusion between  Russia and Donald Trump's 2016  presidential campaign full stop